the Joe Rogan experience do you run
virus scans and all kinds of [ __ ] and do
you cover your webcam with tape when
you're beaten off I I should start doing
that I do run virus scans I do not cover
my webcam with tape when I wonder some
[ __ ] fork and rolls in there let them
let them watch maybe they get an alert
whenever you porn gets pulled up in your
brows like didn't mean evening and they
run they're in there their parents house
the mom and dad are screaming each other
drunken slurs and they hear Dean Dean
Dean easy excuse me Michael Mouse's
jerking off try to go and they run down
the basement bolt the door shut
they're gonna see quite a show imagine
imagine if they found a guy dead because
he was so excited to beat off watching
you beat off that he tripped fallen down
the stairs and broke his neck hot pants
half down and and the cops break in and
find out what the [ __ ] going on and
it's you jerking off on a webcam this
guy's dead with his neck snaps at the
bottom of the stairs his pants half down
well given how many people jerk off to
watching me jerk off statistically
that's gonna happen at some point yeah
that's what I'm saying would you be
excited yes
would you yeah that's awesome I'd be
like that guy went out with a bang
yeah like my [ __ ] killed him did for sure
there's people right now looking through
like perverts looking through somehow or
another getting through a webcam and
watching someone oh of course
for sure of course and especially people
work for the government they talked
about I thought this was exposed
fascinating though they can do that it's
listen if you ever window into my life
though it's the opposite of fascinating
I assure you it is really I'm one I'm
about five minutes away from being Terri
Schiavo what is this employees yeah
Hasan's ring I've been spying on Costas
videos around Christmas for they're like
people were just getting on their
cameras talking to the kids like hey I'm
Shanna go tell your parents that this is
lots of them
this is there so much [ __ ] over yeah
I've heard that that they were actually
talking to people through the device and
that one guy was terrorizing some woman
who's like like telling her was gonna
kill her through the device oh my god
that's a crime yeah yeah yeah Captain
Obvious Jesus Christ oh I got it upgrade
you see private obvious message my
friend really bad there's something
called like the annoying thing I forgot
it's called and you said it and it goes
and it goes up at random times so I put
it under her bed and I forgot and then
the next morning I get a text that just
goes idiot like oh yeah she's like well
now you know it you're an idiot cuz you
terrified me hey do you worry about apps
like Android apps being corrupted like
they apparently don't have a stringent a
testing I don't have that many apps and
I'm much more of a desktop person I'm
not on my phone that much because I'm
like a recluse are you still a recluse
why don't you get out do what outside is
scary I mean meet Pete I don't ever meet
anyone and I don't know where to go to
meet people Oh Christmas movie there's
gonna be eight days with seven days we
fail yeah and then the eighth day yeah
let's get out of Sanwa you don't you
don't go out I don't know no and it's
it's kind of a fort I'd also don't get
along with most people I'm not Fred I
don't believe that because you're easy
to get along with that's confusing to me
but they're not easy to get along with I
think a lot of people are basic as hell
and they don't bring anything to the
conversation there's a lot of that yeah
yeah you got to find better people to
hang out with you know how you do that
you go outside I should just bro I have
a good crew so if so listen I'll tell
you this my friend map the one who was
molested we had friends giving and I
said Matt you have a unique opportunity
to make this the most Awkward
Thanksgiving in history sit these people
all like you there they're your friends
sit down and tell them that this
happened and he's like I can't do it I
go okay how about this I'll do it if I
do it against her what if I do it
against her will I wouldn't really be
wrong given this story he's like dude
and I didn't do it but it would have
been funny he's got a small amount of
time would have been funny
and then he would had just deal with the
weight of all these people which is also
funny
maybe she stay as a recluse
I think you're doing good okay maybe one
of the only dudes is mastered it yeah
the Unabomber is your calling
[Applause]